this is a nightmare
what's up everybody the end is almost
upon us the second to last episode of
loki is here
it's time for us to dive in i hope
you've already watched it because this
is a spoiler full recap of loki episode
5 journey into mystery
aka the one in which we see all signs
point to king
i'm carlos bustamante and this is et
canada's nerd
what is this place where are we who are
you this is the void that's goliath
and where his lunch come on
get a quick setup from classic loki off
the top to get this episode going
it's not some post-apocalyptic nyc loki
got pruned to
he is now in the void and has to survive
a giant cloud beast
called elias now eliath in the comics it
should be noted
is a being that's not bound by time and
has a strong connection to
kang the conqueror allieth rules over a
temporal empire
larger than kang's going back to the
dawn of time and is a major threat to
the villain
it's characterized in this episode is
kind of like a guard dog there's
actually so much more
and could be a missing link between the
tva
and kang if this is in fact all about
king i'm telling you this willingly why
because i want to know who's at the top
of this i want to know who lied to me
at the tva silvie has the upper hand on
rentslayer they're talking about a plan
to find out who's behind the tva and
rensselaer reveals
they're pruning a timeline or a person
doesn't mean death but rather being sent
to the void now apparently no one knows
if there's anything beyond the void
i don't know about that ren slayer here
is really stalling for time in order for
some hunters to arrive
and capture sylvie now sylvia then
escapes by proving herself
and being sent to the void
you let a child command you you'll do
well to respect the boy
this is his kingdom right what was your
nexus event your majesty
i killed bull back in the void you gotta
love how the different loki's
personalities shine through
turns out kid loki killed his thor
further proving that our loki is far
from you know
the most dangerous boastful loki is a
liar on a grand scale like any good loki
should be
alligator loki is clearly the smartest
and most charming clearly
and classic loki is loki who lived long
enough to see the error of his ways
only getting captured by the tva when
emerging from self-imposed exile
the loki's are known as gods of mischief
and lies but classic loki understands
something else
about who they are because we my friends
have but one part to play
the god of outcasts
when our loki plans to leave and destroy
elias a gang of more
evil loki's shows up led by president
locators come on what's to expect this
is one of the first images that we saw
in this series
and we've been waiting to see how this
particular version of loki plays into
the whole deal
i have to say the events that follow
this gang's introduction
do not disappoint loki's lying to and
betraying each other
is like the most low-key thing ever
alligator loki biting off president
loki's arm is
hilarious and the way our loki cringes
through all the chaos
brilliant catching up with sylvia she
wakes up in the void
and is immediately chased by elia she
connects with it
for a brief moment and sees a vision of
what looks like a castle
more on that later before she can get
devoured by the smoke though
akara comes to pick her up and driving
it none other than mobius
still no jet ski by the way you should
be careful just jumping into a
stranger's car like that
when sylvia and mobius meet up with loki
and his merry bandits
loki's they disagree on the best way to
deal with eliath loki of course wants to
destroy it
sylvia says enchanting it would be
better loki tries to mansplain but
silvie is having
none of it i'm going to enchant it
that's insane right as insane as what
paper cutting a giant cloud to death
listen
i've been down here a bit longer than
you i'm going to enchant it
she's pretty confident at the tva
rensselaer begins to interrogate hunter
b-15
b-15 sees right through her saying
rensselaer wants to find out who's
behind the tva too but sylvie will do it
first
because even though renslayer wants it
sylvie needs it
you'll never find them not before she
does
and why is that
[Music]
you only want it
[Music]
she needs it okay kang break just want
to remind everybody in case he forgot
that in the comics renslayer has a
direct connection to kang
even having taken over to rule kang's
empire when the conqueror was
essentially in a coma
is it possible that this show's red
slayer actually knows that kang's behind
all this
and is maybe trying to protect him yeah
i don't know anyway back to it
so just like that you're turning on the
very thing you diverted your life to
it's never too late to change
mobius classic loki kid loki and gator
loki get to chatting
mobius wants to head back to the tva and
expose its lies
ooh see that loki look that my friends
is foreshadowing
loki and sylvia talk about mobius and
their moment on momentous
they both outwardly deny mobius theory
about the nexus event being caused by
them falling in love but they keep
making googly eyes and biting their lips
and i'm not here for it
you know this sylvia admits she's not
used to having friends or
anyone for that matter now what what if
now hear me out here what if
sylvie is playing the long game getting
loki all in his feelings and in the end
her betrayal isn't stabbing him in the
back like a typical loki
but stabbing him in the heart maybe even
literally
not that i'd want to see that i'm not
saying that i like sylvia a lot i don't
want to be a villain but i mean
feel free to discuss the group prepares
to face elia with the 10-pad they could
all leave but the loki's
stay after hug with loki that solidifies
their bromance
mobius hops in the portal presumably
heading back to the tva
what will you do at the tva
[Music]
burn it to the ground
he really gets the best lives in the
series doesn't he sylvia and loki face
down alive with sylvia encouraging loki
to do enchantment like she does
they try to enchant it but to no avail
it's then a classic loki conjures a
massive vision of asgard to distract the
beast
and dies a hero's death when this
distraction works
alas poor loki i knew him well except
not really because we just met him
like last episode and then a little bit
in this episode but
it really hurts to have him stick around
a little bit longer
sylvie and loki try their wonder twins
enchantment again and it works this time
and they see the massive mysterious
castle from earlier
now whose castle could it be
what marvel villain has some sort of
castle or citadel
on the outskirts of time
hidden away in limbo the answer of
course
is doctor doom just kidding obviously
has got to be king right
well even if it's somehow not we'll
definitely likely
probably find out who's behind all this
time madness
and loki wraps up with its final episode
next week
all right what was your favorite easter
egg slash relic from the void was it
throg in a jar the head of the living
tribunal
or maybe the one thing missing from
infinity war that would have made thanos
truly terrifying
thanos copter get into it in the
comments below and join me next week for
the final noodle
loki round table for myself and some
genius level special guests
will dissect what happens in the season
finale and share our thoughts on the
show
in its entirety thank you so much for
watching everyone
you